Another type of classic mistakes are process-related mistakes. And also
in this case, these kind of mistakes can be due
to many reasons. And they are of many types. One
typical example are scheduling issues, which are due to the fact
of being unable to come up with a realistic schedule.
So to have an overly optimistic schedule. And this can be
because we underestimate the effort involved in different parts of
the project. Because we overestimate the ability of the people involved.
Because we overestimate the importance, for example, of the use
of tools. But no matter what the reason is, the
result is typically that the projects end up being late,
which is a very common situation. So this is somehow
related to planning. And in general, planning is a fundamental
factor in software processes and in software development. Mistakes in
planning, such as insufficient planning or abandoning planning due to
pressure, usually lead inexorably to failure. And speaking of failures,
often there are unforeseen failures. Such as
failures on the constructor's end, for example,
that might lead to low quality or
late deliverables, which ultimately affects the downstream activities.